باللغه العلميه عندما نتحدث عن سبعه فاصله
تسع درجات اليوم يجري تقييم احتمال حدوث
موجات مد عملاقه تسونامي هل هذا كلام معقد
دقيق هل هذا كلام مبالغ فيه ام ماذا يعني
انا انا بعتقد مبالغ فيه لانه لو بدها
تصير كانت صارت وخلصت يعني الزلزال تسجل
الساعه ثلاثه و18 دقيقه يعني صار قاطع
لهلا ثلاث ساعات ثلاث ساعات وشوي يعني لو
بدها تصير كانت صارت هلا سجل ارتفاع
بمستوى البحر ببعض المناطق بتركيا بس
بعدنا عم نحكي بشنطه يعني 25 سم بعدها لا
تعد موجات وانا بعتقد لو بدها تصير كانت
صارت اها طيب دكتوره تمارا كيف نفسر بانه
الزلزال يعني وقع في عمق الجنوب التركي
ولكن اثره امتد الى اكثر من منطقه ونتحدث
عن ضحايا اكبر في بلدان مجاوره وليس في
الجنوب التركي حيث وقع مركز الزلزال
انه نحس بالزلزال هيدي شغله كتير طبيعيه
يعني نحن بتعرفي الصفائح التكتونيه كلها
موصوله ببعضها نحن خاصه
بين تركيا سوريه العراق لبنان فلسطين
وصولها لمصر يعني انت بعدك عم تحكي بنفس
المنطقه فطبيعي كتير نشعر بالزلزال هلا
مستوى الاضرار عاده بيتعلق كمان بطبيعه
الابنيه بالاماكن اللي بنيت عليها الابنيه
ومن هيك احيانا بتشوف يعني يمكن بالمنطقه
فيها الزلزال احيانا بيكون الضرر اقل لانه
يمكن المباني بتكون شيدت بطريقه افضل
بطريقه تراعي اكثر شروط الزلازل والهزات
وللاسف يعني ببعض الدول يمكن يكون ما في
احترام كافي لهذه الشروط وبالتالي
حتى احيانا بتكون يمكن اقل من هيك الهزه
وبتعمل عندهم اضرار